hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today
i will be breaking down the latest new
magic twist
in black clover that shocked almost
everyone in the fan base
first we had the confirmation that
asta's devil union
mode is still incomplete which in itself
is a big deal and will have major
implications on the story
and then we saw the reveal of a crazy
new magic spell that allowed one of the
weaker characters to go
toe-to-toe against one of the absolutely
strongest villains
in the entire story this was just so
crazy
and so much fun so let's talk about it
if you enjoyed the black clover content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going
just leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you are new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications the only way to make
sure that you won't miss a bunch of our
videos in the future
is to subscribe hit that notification
bell and then select the option that
says
all a big thank you to all of our anime
opera patrons for making videos like
this one
possible i'll talk more about patreon at
the end of the video but now
please be advised that this video will
of course contain black lower manga
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned okay so the latest
chapter confirms that lilith and amma's
fused form
has in fact been completely defeated by
asta
and liebe's anti-magic the body of the
fused devil disintegrated
into ash so there won't be some sort of
crazy devil resurrection magic that
brings them back
they really are gone with an assist from
knocked
austen liebe just managed to defeat the
fused form of two high-strength devils
who emerged from the underworld
with their original bodies sure they
came from the first floor and the devils
on the lower floors are believed to be
even stronger
but this is still a massive
accomplishment for osta and liebe
after lilith and ama almost killed
knocked while just toying with him
this type of outcome to the battle
really demonstrates just how much
stronger asta has become
in such a short period of time now as we
know
austen libis devil union form wore off
right after they took the fused
devil down so now asta is back in his
base form and liba is back in his chibi
form
knocked then says something interesting
he says that austin liba did really well
especially because their devil union
form is not
complete yet this really caught my
attention because i'm wondering what
exactly knocked means
by complete is he just talking about the
time limit so what he means is
when the devil union mode is complete
asta and libya will be able to stay in
that mode for a longer period of time
or is knocked suggesting that there is
more to the devil union form
and once asta unlocks the complete
version of it will he be able to attain
a new and even stronger
transformation imagine if devil union
was like ultra instinct
and asta is yet to attain the mastered
ultra instinct form i mean the mastered
devil union form that would be a pretty
massive development but we will have to
wait and see
however as fun as it is to think about
austin liba attaining even further power
ups and learning how to use
mastered ultra instinct and all that
good stuff right now the situation
isn't all that great for asta and liba
like yes the fused devil was defeated
and that part is great
but asta says that after this fight
against
the fused devil he won't be able to use
the devil union mode
or even the black ostaform for at least
30 minutes and 30 minutes is a long
long time in an intense multifaceted
battle
such as this one since anti-magic seems
to be the single most effective weapon
for taking down
highest ranked devils the idea of having
osta
out of the fight for 30 minutes is
pretty scary
to be fair asta can still use anti-magic
in his base form so he can still fight
weaker opponents but if another highest
ranked devil
emerges from the cliff off before the 30
minutes are up
and if this devil turns out to be even
stronger than lilith
and the mom everyone will be pretty
screwed including
asta this means that the black bulls and
the other members of the infiltration
squad
need to defeat the dark triad right away
they need to
take out the dark triad and stop the
cliffhoth ritual before the next gate is
opened and before
morris makes his next deadly move
but right now the dark triad can use 100
of their devil's power so that means
that they won't
be easy to take down the focus of the
chapter then switches back to the fight
between
dante and jack jack is doing his best
and he is cutting and slashing dante
over and over and over again but as
strong as jack's slash magic
is with its ability to adapt to the
magic of his opponent
jack's slashing simply cannot overcome
dante's overpowered body magic which
allows dante to just keep regenerating
no matter how many times he is cut we
really have to show some respect for
jack here he is fighting like crazy and
he refuses to give up
even though it is clear that he simply
cannot overpower
dante jack really is a fierce and
determined warrior
and he refuses to give up no matter what
so i have to say that he really is a
worthy rival
to our boy yami i don't think he'll ever
be able to defeat yami but still
respect even dante acknowledges jack's
strength and courage
and he is grateful to jack for giving
him a good fight
however dante announces that this fight
is now
over and he prepares to destroy jack but
before dante can kill
jack the entire upper half of his body
is blown to bits by a massive exploding
fireball as dante regenerates he sees
none other than magna and zora emerging
from the smoke
and heading right for him magna and zora
both
smirk as they stare dante down and then
magna does
something insane he challenges dante
directly
when he first sees them dante is not
impressed at all
in fact he is visibly disappointed he
can tell that magda and zora don't have
special magic attributes or exceptional
levels of mana
so dante feels that fighting against
them would be pointless
they are far too weak and even if both
of them attacked dante together
beating them would be too easy it's
almost insulting for creatures like them
to
even challenge dante at least in dante's
mind
but magna just smirks and says that
dante
won't be fighting the two of them he
will be fighting magna
alone which just makes dante laugh and
it makes everyone reading the chapter go
wait what magna are you actually serious
bro
dante is so confident that magna can't
do anything to him that he has no
intention of even using his magic
he basically tells magnet to attack him
all he wants
and then leave in shame when he realizes
that he cannot do anything to dante
but it turns out that magna has a trick
up his sleeve
and a clean shot at dante is exactly
what he was hoping for
magna hits dante with another fireball
but this time
it wasn't just a fireball this fireball
spell
allows magna to attach a magical chain
to dante's body
a chain that looks like it was created
through some form of
trap magic it's as if zora taught magna
to use some sort of flame trap magic
hybrid one end of the chain is attached
to dante
and the other is attached to magna and
as a direct result
of this new flame trap magic dante's
ability to use
100 of his devil's power disappears
magna was somehow able to create a crazy
new
magic spell a spell referred to as
hidden fire magic soul chain death match
in the unofficial translation
and the crazy thing about this spell is
that it allows magna to add his own
magic
and his opponent's magic together and
then divide their magic equally between
the two opponents
since dante is of course way stronger
than magna
this spell is about to make magna much
much stronger than he was before
and of course it will also make dante
way weaker than he was before
so yeah that's a pretty damn good deal
for magna
as magnus starts landing actual blows on
dante
he vows to show the dark triad the true
power of the low-class
magic knights and he also vows to be the
one who will blow
dante up and that is how this crazy
surprise-filled chapter ends
whoa who would have thought that magna
swing would be the one to go
toe-to-toe against dante of the dark
triad the human host of lucifer himself
that is totally insane but at the same
time it's very fun
and very satisfying after what magna had
to go through
in the heart kingdom we knew that he had
a lot to prove and that he would
eventually come back with
a major power up but this is something
else
this new spell that allows magna to
attach a chain to his opponent
add up their collective magic and then
divide it equally between them
reminds me of something you'd see in
like hunter hunter the chain especially
reminds me of kurapika
and his fight against uvogin on paper
uvogin was supposed to be much stronger
than kurapika
and yet with a very creative use of his
nen
kurapika was able to gain the upper hand
here too we have a clearly weaker mage
using a very unique spell
to gain the upper hand against a much
stronger opponent
in a creative way i thought that this
was extremely cool
but this could also become a serious
game changer moving forward
if tabata decides to introduce more
unique magic spells like this one
with specific conditions that offer
major advantages under the right
circumstances
we could end up seeing more mages who up
to this point were considered weak
becoming much more relevant in some of
the major fights that are going to come
in the future personally i am fully
expecting that demon lord
sekei will be the one to take down
lucifer
but back to zora and magna these guys
have been training together
and it's clear that they've been
thinking outside the box when it comes
to their training
so far it looks like their strategy has
paid off handsomely
and you absolutely love to see it after
everything that these guys have been
through as commoners whose magic
capabilities have constantly been
belittled by others
it's just so satisfying to see them
thinking outside the box
and using that type of thinking to gain
the upper hand on someone like dante
and all of this is even more satisfying
when we see that magna and zora were
actually
there during the yami and asta vs dante
fight they were watching everything from
a distance
but at the time they knew that they were
too weak to help
their special magic techniques were not
yet perfected
so they had to watch helplessly as their
captain was abducted by xenon
right before their eyes but now magna
and zora
are finally having their moment in the
sun they finally have a chance to make a
real difference
and help their comrades in this decisive
moment
and i am here for it let me know what
you guys thought of this chapter
including that reveal about asta's devil
union mode being
incomplete and the shocking new spell
that magna just
unlocked do you think that zora also has
some new trick
up his sleeve that is also on this level
of crazy and do you think that zora and
magna will be able to make a real
difference
in this fight i mean just seeing magna
punching dante in the face was
absolutely beautiful
but can this continue can these guys
really threaten dante
in any meaningful way in the long term
don't forget to leave your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black lover content right here on
the channel
just leave that like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you are new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
please make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications the only way to make
sure that you won't miss a bunch of our
videos in the future
is to subscribe hit that notification
bell and then also select the option
that says
all i know it's annoying it's an extra
step but
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma red
haired raven
and avi these guys are absolute mad lads
and disciples of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrata pate heffa algertol dr
cortman the toasted qi
bang emperor otaku spidey life tinel
tungsten tarquez baked buddhist
and you know finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
rothlin de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joy and
garcia ted no ted iceparky65 jessica
lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see us peace cowboys
[Music]
you